hello everyone it's that time again when
i
decide to answer some of your questions
so i've asked you both on our patreon
page and also on my regular
channel to ask some questions and i will
do my best to answer them
and as always we will begin with my
patrons
who always have priority in these kinds
of videos
beginning with nadim sabik
who asks do you measure how much time
you invest in every video you make in
summary
if yes how long does it take an average
to prepare for a video and how much to
record it
that can be look very different from
video to video
for some videos i have
a lot of the information already
in there in my head so to speak which
means i don't have to do as much
research before writing the script
of course i have to double check my
sources and all that still but
it's not the same amount of research
for those videos like sometimes i write
a script in
a few hours um for other scripts it can
take like
months of research i remember i did the
arabi video which i mean i did research
on that for
for years but not specifically for that
video but writing that script
took a couple of months not just because
it was so long but also because there
was so much that i wanted
to cram in there so it really differs
like some scripts will take months some
will take
an hour or two um
but usually so i guess like a standard
would be that
maybe i'll do research for a week
like really read all the literature um
sometimes have to buy new literature
to do some research i'll i'll i'll do
that for
a week or two just interiorizing all the
information
and then i will write a script which
usually
like a standard time would be i'll do it
in a day or two like
a few hour sessions each day so take
about two days perhaps
and then i'll shoot the video which
usually takes
between like an hour an hour and a half
if it goes well sometimes two hours um
so give or take i would say that that's
about how long that takes
and then the editing which is perhaps at
least for me
some of the most time and energy
consuming
part of the process i usually do
in the span of a week
so i'll do sessions of
three hours each sometimes like three
hours in the morning and then three
hours at night
and if i start on monday i'll usually be
done by thursday
or something like that and then the
video is out by sunday this can also
differ a lot depending on how much i
work at my day job or and so on but i
try to keep a schedule of working at
least
a couple of hours every day if i have a
video coming out
so in summary it can take
everything from a couple of months to a
day or two i did
there was a video i did the other week i
think it was the margarite video
like i wrote it shot it the same day and
then edited it the next day so that was
done like within 24 hours
of course i'd done research prior to
that but so it really differs a lot but
usually i'd say the process of a full
video takes about two
weeks in total of of work second
question from
nadeem is is it possible for you to
create a schedule
so we know what topics is coming out
when or does the schedule narrow down or
kill your inspiration
not necessarily kill my inspiration but
i think
i rarely know what video i'm doing next
it's usually just
me looking at my bookshelf and going
what do i feel like reading this week
and then i'll
base the video on that so i it would be
as it looks right now would be difficult
for me to do a schedule like that i
could
perhaps give you
a warning like a week or two before if i
know what script i'm currently writing
and so on but
a longer schedule like that would be
difficult uh for me
we also have two questions from a tibet
tagistani
first he asked do you think the sharia
or exoteric law should be
broken like a shell in order to access
the gnosis or
like the fruit inside the shell that
seems like a question more for
an islamic scholar um
since i like that's a subjective
theological question that i don't really
have an answer to in that sense but that
certainly that would be i would say the
opinion of the
majority it depends on what you mean but
that would be the opinion that many
sufis would have for example that the
exterior law
of the religion is important and is
never neglected
but that that can be you can sort of
dive deeper within that and find the
inner truths
there's this an analogy used by a lot of
sufis
of a person in a boat
trying to find like a pearl
out in the ocean let me see if i
remember this so he is in a
in a row boat and the boat is the sharia
that is the exterior law
that is needed in order to to travel on
the water in other words to travel in
life
the the oars it's called auras right
the oars uh represent the tariqa in the
sufi sense so the the path
uh the spiritual path that that gets you
to your destination
and then he dives down into the water
and then there are two other terms which
is
which means knowledge and that is
represented by
i can't remember what the analogy is for
that but i guess it's like basically his
ability to see underwater
would be the modifier and then he finds
the
the pearl which would be the truth the
spiritual truth at the heart of it all
and that's like a very common way to
look at these things within sufism
that all of these parts are required
you need the sharia you need the tariqah
in order to
have the ma'arifa to find the hakhira
so to say so uh and tibet's second
question is do you practice any kind of
spiritual ritual
yes i do and that's all i will say on
that subject
the patron faris al rosabi asks what is
the most complex
religious belief you have come across
and what is the simplest
that is an impossible question the most
complex religious belief
and i've been reading a lot about
valentinian
gnosticism lately and like gnosticism
generally is just
so crazy um it's just so complicated and
has so many aspects and eons and
beings and it like makes no sense
a lot of the time that says more about
me perhaps but but i think gnosticism
and similar related movements
are some of the most complex and
difficult
metaphysical systems if you want to call
it a system even
that you can find the simplest is a lot
more
difficult does atheism count as like
there's
not a belief in in any god that's pretty
simple
although it often comes with a lot of
other things too um
if atheism doesn't count then then i
have a very hard time coming up with an
answer for that question
i really don't think i can come up with
anything
that i would say is the most simple i
would love to hear in the comments if
any of you have any
religious beliefs that you think are are
very simple like many
many religions will claim that theirs
are the most simple
i've the a lot of the time i've spent
with muslims for example
they will say like islam is very simple
it's a very simple religion
and many religions may appear to be very
simple on the surface
but then when you dive deeper there is a
lot of complexity like there's no
religion that
isn't very complex and
diverse and all of this so i i really
couldn't pick out one of them to say
that
they are the most simple sorry i
couldn't answer
that part of your question but i really
can't come up with anything
uh second question everyone seems to be
asking two questions this time
uh given that certain mystical practices
for example sufism attempts to express
ideas are inexpressible within the
limitations of language
and therefore resort to the use of
elliptical meanings
encompassed in metaphors and poetry how
transmissible
are these ideas when people will
inevitably interpret the metaphors and
poetry
differently i mean that yeah that you
basically answered your own question it
it it isn't like at least that's what
these mystics
say like rumi begins the mass navy by
saying
hey i'm gonna say things about
stuff but none of that none of what i
will say
will actually correspond to that which
i'm trying to say
and that's a very recurring theme in all
of
mysticism and in like apathic theology
or metaphysics generally
the idea that when it comes to the
absolute reality
whether you call that god or the one or
whatever
nothing can be expressed about it it's
completely beyond human
uh conception beyond human understanding
and any words will fail or at worst
even complicate things or or or confuse
us even more about what's actually going
on
and they will say that the best response
to all of this is actually silence
or just basically to experience it
yourself and that
person who hasn't experienced that kind
of
reality can never truly understand what
those mystics are saying and so
based on that i mean in from one
perspective it's it's
pointless not pointless i guess but it's
it's useless to try to express it
because there's there's no way you can
because that's the very nature of that
stuff like that's
everything from platinus and late
platonism to
i guess hermeticism to the christian
church fathers and the orthodox church
and and not just that like
all of christianity and islam and sufism
like has this perspective of god being
completely ineffable
and beyond any anything any any thing
that can be
grasped and any likeness to to anything
in the universe that we experience
at least in one sense so i don't know i
guess
how how transmissible are these ideas i
guess they aren't really
maybe they can point the finger in a
certain direction
and one aspect of apophatic theology is
that we can say
what god isn't we cannot say what he is
so we can say that god
isn't ignorant or god isn't
i don't know god isn't dead but we
cannot say any positive characteristics
about god
and if you're one of those theologians
then
i guess you could argue that the best
you can do is point the way
but you can never fully explain or
get to the point as it were okay so
barbara copely asks could you expand
upon the history of the kaaba
that you presented in your video about
religion and pre-islamic arabia
and add more details about the history
of the hajj you
gave some tantalizing hints about
pre-islamic pilgrimages yes
it's a very interesting subject
indeed the evidence suggests as does the
traditional islamic account that
hajj or pilgrimage was
an important part of the religious
practices in pre-islamic arabia
the kaaba in mecca seems to have been a
very important
such shrine that people did go to for
pilgrimage
but that there were also many other such
shrines around the peninsula
we have inscriptions that will say you
know i don't know
ahmad went on hajj to
the shrine of rudow in
some part of eastern arabia or whatever
like there are
there are examples like that and there
are also interesting questions as to
how that then translated into the what
became the hajj of
the muslims many muslims of course
themselves will
will claim that all those practices that
were
that is shared with the pre-islamic
arabs were actually
characteristics of an earlier pure
monotheism
that was brought by abraham or ibrahim
in arabic
and ishmael and that that was then
corrupted
just like all other religions have been
corrupted from this pure monotheism
but that certain aspects of that pure
monotheism has remained
including for example this hajj to the
kaaba and that
what muhammad does is really just to to
reverse that corruption and to
reinstate the original
form of the pilgrimage so to say like
that's a that's a normative
confessional islamic perspective on that
from a historical critical perspective
the question is very interesting
when we consider how did the pre-islamic
hajj translate into the
islamic hajj that's the best i can do
for now
that stuff is still very much unexplored
or underexplored and there is
more information to emerge still when it
comes to pre-islamic arabian
religion but as i said in the video like
that's a field that's
just giving us new information all the
time so i'm sure we'll find out more
about that
very shortly absolute asks have you come
across the work of andre
corban and would you be willing to make
a video about the themes he covered and
the perennial philosophy aspect
i've certainly come across his writings
he is
very famous in the study of
islam islamic studies in the 20th
century but also particularly in
sufism and and shiism
he is connected while not necessarily
part of that
i guess but he's definitely connected to
the perennial philosophy
as represented by rene guanon and
said nasser and fritjav shuwon and so on
he's part of that larger group and his
writings have been
very interesting there are some of it i
would argue is a bit
dated i agree in my video about sufism
that
many writers in the last century have
perhaps overemphasized the philosophical
metaphysical aspects of sufism
and sort of downplay the the
practical ritualistic aspects of sufism
which really is
at least my opinion the most central uh
but still like
his his writings is very influential
very important
and i will be talking about the
perennial philosophy and i will of
course be mentioning and discussing the
works of andre kaban
also so so yes um you can look forward
to me
exploring that further in the future
that's what i'm planning at least
thomas blase uh what kind of influence
did the virtue and period of muslim
knights have on the development of
chivalric ethos in medieval latin
christendom
do you agree with those scholars who
claim that the influence was substantial
that's a bit outside of my field of
knowledge
i would
i would definitely think that that had
an impact the islamic
religion or the like the islamic islamic
jurisprudence
had a very developed system um
or tradition of just
war for example um just like europe did
but the islamic world very early on the
islamic law
developed a very complex and deep
tradition of
just practice in war it's like what is
allowed in war
like no women or children are allowed to
be killed
no non-combatants basically are allowed
to be killed at least by the majority of
scholars
like there's this very developed
tradition
within that that must have had an
impact it's a difficult question to
answer there's a great story
um about imam ali
the cousin and son-in-law of the prophet
muhammad where he said that
he there's this battle ali is part of
this battle
and he is fighting and then he is
fighting this particular enemy who he
has just defeated and he's about to
strike him down so kill him with a sword
just as he raises his sword to
to kill him this other person spits in
his face
which results in ali lowering his sword
and backing off
and then the other guy asked like what
are you doing why didn't you kill me he
said
before i was going to kill you for the
sake of god
but when you spit in my face i became
angry
and so now i can't now he couldn't kill
him so
there's definitely a tradition within
the islamic religion of
the chevrolet behavior in in
war context but also outside but that is
a field that i don't know that much
about
i just really like that story i think
it's very uh it's
it's very telling it's it's very uh it's
very colorful and
very uh striking also in a way there is
great literature about that i believe
that
who is the grandson of inaudible
pioneers of of sufism in the 20th
century
who is the current period or leader of
the inayatya
tariqa of sufism in the united states i
believe he has written it might have
been his phd
actually on this subject you should
probably look that up
um if i forget to link that in the
description
it's piazzi i know khan so look that up
then we have my wonderful patron with
letters that i can't really
pronounce but i'll leave your name here
he asks how different are beliefs of
a modern believer from a believer a
thousand years ago let's imagine a
muslim from today's medina and from
medina around the year
a thousand ce and that they meet will
they acknowledge each other as muslims
or would they classify each others as
non-believers and heretics
and the same question about christianity
very interesting question
um i think if we take a roman catholic
from
a thousand well i guess catholicism
as a separate thing didn't really exist
at that point but if you take a
christian from a thousand
a d or c e and
he meets a christian from now i think
that christian the first one would be
very confused about what's going on
because that's nature of religions that
they always change even though
people who belong to those religions
will often
deny that that happens and will claim
that our religion is
unchanged from the beginning that is
never true
it's impossible and so i think
inevitably if people
from a certain religion met their
co-religionists from a thousand years
before
there's going to be a lot of confusion
and a lot of debate about who is doing
things right
um although of course there are certain
key features that they would agree on
uh a christian today and a christian
back then would agree
on the trinity and jesus as the son of
god
and and the bible as the most important
scripture saying for a muslim they would
all agree that the quran
is central they would all agree that
muhammad was
the last prophet or at least the seal of
the prophets how we want to interpret
that
and that most likely they would also
affirm the importance of the sunnah of
the prophet saw but they might
interpret what the sunnah is differently
they might have a very different idea
about how that should be
applied they might have a very different
idea about how the quran should be
interpreted
at least some of it there could be those
discrepancies but i think
in some cases i think they could agree
on on core features
but for the most part i think there
would be a huge rift
of time i mean it is and that that would
cause a lot of confusion
and and difference between these two
hypothetical persons
because as i said religions the way they
are
practiced the way they are understood
will always change and develop
with time and across different regions
and places
that's the way religion functions and
and so
i think naturally that would be the
outcome of a meeting like that
okay on our discord chat the
user unsrdjost asks if it can be
measured
when did the caliphates with the
exception of the ottomans
become muslim majority states or in
other words for how long did they remain
non-muslim majority
what would contribute to the speed of
the conversion rate
uh yes this is a very interesting topic
because indeed the early muslims as they
conquered
the middle east and north africa and and
persia
and all these regions they weren't
really interested
in converting people
for forced conversions while they did
happen
and there were loopholes in which they
happened generally they
it wasn't really practiced especially
not early on
there is a line from the quran that says
there is no
there shall be no compulsion in
religions so
the muslims with this in mind they
didn't want to convert the entire world
to islam
they wanted to conquer these regions
they
they they ruled over them but they
didn't convert people forcibly
there are exceptions to this there were
the the al-mohads
in the 12th century in spain and north
africa
where forced conversions did take place
um
and and that's just one example that it
has happened of course
but as a general practice it wasn't and
so for the first
couple of hundred years after the muslim
conquests
they were still a minority they ruled
but as a minority group within this vast
empire
because christians were still there jews
were still there
other various different groups
zoroastrians
hindus were allowed for the most part to
practice their religion
of course as you could say second-class
religions or second-class citizens
as long as they paid the jazzy attacks
they were allowed to practice their
religion
and no one would force them to convert
to islam
and so it's hard to say exactly when
the muslims became the majority but it
took a couple of centuries i think it
would be
when it comes to the central middle east
at least you talked like syria
iraq and north africa like egypt and
these places
it would probably be like around the
year thousand perhaps a bit later
that would be almost 400 years after the
conquest i think it's around that time
that the muslims started to actually
become the majority of the population
there are different reasons for this i
think one of the main reasons is the
fact
that becoming muslims
was convenient for a lot of people
because if you became a muslims
if you became a muslim i'm sorry you
didn't have to
pay the jizya tax so there wasn't as
much tax imposed upon you
you were you gained
i mean you did gain certain more
freedoms and rights in society
even though theoretically the christians
and jews and other religious groups as
long as they pay the tax
we're supposed to have equal rights with
the muslims that of course
wasn't always true in practice and so if
you became a muslims that
meant things became a lot easier for you
and i think that was one of the main
reasons
that this gradual process happened that
people started to convert and
and of course for a lot of people they
probably were convinced that islam was
true also
let's not minimize that aspect of it too
but i think the social aspect is very
important here
and that became actually a problem for a
lot of the muslim rulers as i said the
early muslims
especially under the umayyads and the uh
and the very early muslim leaders they
weren't very interested
in converting people sometimes they were
even hostile to the idea of converting
people
for economic and and political reasons
because the judea tax that was paid by
minority or
not minority groups but non-islamic
religions was a
great source of income for the
caliphates and if everyone would start
to convert to islam they would lose a
significant
they would lose that significant income
and that would economically
affect them very negatively and so the
early muslims were
sometimes even trying to discourage
people from converting
and when they then started to do that
there was some
some pushback but eventually of course
things changed and
since like the middle ages the
mid middle ages or late middle ages
muslims
had become the majority in what we call
the
middle east or the larger islamic world
or islamic
world okay so now we're moving on to the
questions i got from the non-patreon
subscribers i asked on my community page
on youtube
for you to ask some questions and i
received a lot of them almost 100 so i
won't be able to answer
that many of them or this video would go
on for way too long
but asks as a student of religion would
you convert her religion after you have
discovered it to be true
which religion makes more sense i mean
no religion makes more sense
than the other in general at least to me
as as for the other question if i found
out that a religion was
true would i convert to it if if i found
out that it was exclusively true
like definitively like this is the truth
and like yeah i mean then i would
already be converted i guess because i
would
i would be convinced that that religion
was true um
i don't necessarily believe that there
is one religion that has monopoly on
chew or on truth that there's one
religion that is exclusively true
to the detriment of all other religions
um
i think that truth is a very slippery
term
i think many religions and philosophies
can be true
simultaneously really so uh i don't know
but as i said yeah if i found out that
one religion was definitively true
exclusively and absolutely then then i
guess yeah
it would be weird if i didn't convert
alex alpine asks are you continuing your
formal education in religious studies
will we call your professor home someday
i don't know
uh hopefully to answer your question yes
i am continuing my formal education in
religious studies
i have a bit of a bit of a break right
now because i'm in between getting my
masters which i did
two years ago and uh doing a phd
and i'm applying for phd positions i've
done interviews and so on but i
i haven't started any phd positions yet
we'll see
when that happens but the plan is
definitely to continue
the academic studies so to say
as for the professor thing i don't know
god willing will i'll be there one day
if i want to
i don't even know if i want to be there
we'll see sitamu asks can you do some
videos on native american
religion and their various prophets
please the concepts of the great spirit
is very fascinating to read about
as a student of perennial wisdom i've
been thinking about doing stuff about
native american religion lately actually
i really want to do videos on the aztecs
for example the mayans
andrew henry from religion for breakfast
actually did
a video on the aztecs recently which was
amazing so i don't know if i
like there's like there's room for me to
do one because
that one works but i might like
dive deeper into some of the theological
aspects of that there's
a lot of really interesting metaphysical
aspects to the aztec religion about this
concept of teot
but also like the incas and north
american
native american religions i guess i'm
looking forward to it mostly because i
have a lot of research ahead of me and
it's very exciting to learn new things
because it's a field that i don't know
all that much about so i'm very excited
to
to to study it and research it so i can
give you videos about it in the future
that's going to happen soon daniel
overcash asks
do you believe in any kind of aliens or
extraterrestrials and would you do a
video about any religious theories or
legends about aliens
uh yeah oh
i don't know i think the answer to the
first question is
yes because of the classic argument that
the universe seems to be so
infinitely large that it would be
strange if there wasn't
some kind of life form out there but
then again how do you define life form
do we judge that by how we
defined life here on earth as like
intelligent
thinking conscious beings
like where do we draw the line for for
life i think definitely there would be
or not definitely but i do believe that
there should be some kind of bacteria or
that kind of life form out there
somewhere i'm also the opinion that
this as i just said like this line
between life and not
life is very blurry there seems to be
more of a spectrum
and that the idea of life versus not
life is sort of a human
construct in some sense
why isn't a rock more alive than a human
being unless you define that
specifically as
thinking and acting and free will
hypothetically and all this stuff it's a
difficult question
but i think my answer would be yes i i
think there should be some kind of
life similar to us here on earth
somewhere out there i don't know if i
believe that they have
the kind of intelligence or
complex brains that humans do it's
possible
like who am i to say i don't know arpan
singhal asks would you make a video
about how hinduism and islam affected
each other in india
for example the relationship between the
bhakti movement and the sufi movement
also the culture resulting from such
interaction
uh yes and yes and yes and yes i've i've
been
i've i have plans to do more stuff on
india
because india is such an amazing place
when it comes to
i mean all places are but india is such
a fascinating place when it comes to
religion
because there's been so many of them
there always and they've always
co-mingled and interacted in such
interesting ways
we talk about sufism that's true for
that as well
sufis and hindus were in contact
like inevitably i will do videos on dara
shukur for example
it was a mughal prince for those who
don't know who
translated the upanishads and who saw
like so many other muslim sages or
muslim scholars in india
saw the hindu tradition at least as
expressed in vedanta
as being basically expressing the same
truth as what islam was expressing
and darashoku wrote this great work
called the mingling of the two oceans
the
uh um
the the imaginal bahrain which
explores this idea of the unity between
hinduism and islam
there's more of that than than many
people might expect
and i definitely plan on talking about
that in the future
there's a lot of interaction between
those two religious movements
dimitrios cuosis asks me to do a video
on orthodox and oriental christianity
yes i'm working on one right now
roy chamorro asks what good exists in
learning about religions for someone who
is non-religious
and or lacks belief in spirituality
that's a that's a definitely a a
worthwhile question
but i think the answer is that religion
is such an important part of culture of
politics of the world generally of human
experience
like religion is a central aspect of
how we interact as human beings and how
we function
socially and politically and culturally
with each other
and and and individually and so
for anyone who lives in this world and
among other human beings
can gain a lot of benefit from
understanding religion because it will
gain
it will help them gain a better
understanding of human beings in general
and of society in general i think if we
understand better how other people think
um even if it is about things that we
don't believe in
that definitely helps us have better
conversations with each other
and to be able to tolerate each other or
to
respect each other i should say more um
which
in the end hopefully will lead to a
world of
more understanding and friendship and
peace
rather than hatred and things like
war which frankly is quite unnecessary
and
nasty so that would be my
basic uh but important answer
to that question it's a very great
question thank you for asking it
shantanu david asks have you ever
thought of doing a how-to video
on starting your own religion the
results might be interesting
certainly that would be very interesting
that's an indeed that's a very
interesting idea i don't know how it
would work and how i would make it not
problematic and weird and
uh cause trouble in in different ways
um that but that could be a fun video to
do
time on a serious note that could be
very interesting
from the perspective of like breaking
down
what a religion is what are like we
have to make huge generalizations of
course but to break down like what
constitutes
a religion what is the cornerstones of
what make a religion a religion
that could could become a very
interesting academic discussion
of an overview of of religion in general
and
but it could from that perspective it
would be a very fun and light-hearted
way to tackle that very difficult
question so that's not a very
that's a pretty good idea actually
gilstock tv what do you know about the
emerald tablet
i can only find so much information on
the subject until i hit a wall
you're in luck because i'm doing a video
hopefully next week or in the week after
about hermeticism
and it's going to be a collaboration
and the other person whom i will
disclose uh at another point
is actually going to talk about the
emerald tablet
so uh look forward to that pretty soon
you're gonna have
in all likelihood a very interesting a
very interesting video to look forward
to
and to learn about the emerald tablet
it's starting to
there's thunder outside there's a storm
coming here
pazuzu asks have you tried lasagna it's
my favorite i have and i
quite like it actually i since about a
year back i don't eat meat anymore
but there are really good vegetarian
lasagna
alternatives so yeah lasagna is great
i approve of lasagna
and on that note i will have to
end this q a it's always really fun to
answer your questions
some of them are really profound and
deep and some of them are very
light-hearted and
fun nonetheless i appreciate all of you
for
for asking questions i appreciate all of
you for
being there for being subscribers to my
patrons especially i appreciate you
for all of your support
it really is very inspiring to know that
so many of you are interested
in these videos and that you are
searching or are interested
in learning more about
a topic like religion which is becoming
such an important aspect or has always
been
but it's dawning on us that the idea
that people had 40 years ago that
religion was going away
was kind of foolish because it seems to
be going in the opposite direction
at least in some respects and that means
we need to
know more about what that means
uh what religion means and
what we can do to understand it and
navigate in a world where religion
is an important part and i really
appreciate
all the the contact that i can have with
you as an audience and all the wonderful
discussions that we're having
i look forward to to the coming weeks
this some exciting stuff i'm working on
uh videos on hermeticism uh i'm doing
more collaborations i'm doing videos on
the eastern orthodox church
and hesikazim i might do a video on the
arabic language the origins of the
arabic language
there is a lot of ideas mystical
experience in ancient greece i have so
many ideas
that i plan on doing pretty soon and i'm
really excited
about the future so i'll see you
pretty soon i hope you all have a great
week weekend day live and uh
yeah i'll see you next video bye
[Music]
foreign